madame la président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais tout
d'abord remercier les présidents de
groupe et les très nombreux sénateurs
qui ont décidé de consigner cette
proposition de résolution remercier
également le président du Cénac qui lui
confère une solennité particulière en
demandant lui-même son inscription à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat
un an après l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous
avons appris plusieurs leçons
fondamentales la première est l'ampleur
des mensonges que le Kremlin a orchestré
sans relâche depuis des années pour
justifier ses agressions successives
l'Occident est responsable de tout le
temps menace la Russie soutient des
nazis et des criminels de guerre
multiplient les provocations l'Europe et
le valet de l'impérialisme américain ces
discours délirants relayés avec
constance par le parti prorus en Europe
ont trompé beaucoup de monde ils ont
volé en éclat le jour où de juin dernier
à Saint-Pétersbourg ou Poutine lui-même
a fini par avouer ce qu'il pense depuis
toujours l'Ukraine et russe et comme
autant de Pierre Legrand la Russie va
reprendre par la guerre ces territoires
perdus balayer la propagande balayer
tous les mensonges balayer la fable de
l'Occident menaçant empire colonial sous
les tsar la Russie fait le dernier
empire colonial sous le communisme après
la fin des empires anglais et français
elle veut le redevenir et l'on comprend
aujourd'hui le sens de la phrase
prononcée par Poutine en la chute de
l'URSS fut la plus grande catastrophe
politique du XXe siècle parce que la
chute de l'URSS c'était la fin de
l'Empire russe la deuxième leçon de
cette guerre et que l'ampleur de ses
mensonges n'a eu d'égal que l'ampleur de
nos illusions et de nos lâchetés ce
n'est pas l'agressivité de l'Occident
qui a conduit Poutine à envahir
l'Ukraine c'est sa passivité en 2008 les
leaders européens ont refusé à l'Ukraine
et à la Géorgie l'adhésion à l'OTAN pour
ne pas irriter Poutine quelques mois
plus tard il envahissait la Géorgie
quand il a envahi la Crimée nous avons
un nouveau répondu avec des sanctions
bien modestes il est clair que les
craintes infondées de provoquer Poutine
ont le convainquant de notre faiblesse
ont ouvert la voie à l'invasion totale
de 2022
cette erreur majeure d'analyse fut
d'abord celle de l'Allemagne et de la
France depuis 30 ans la politique
allemande est fondée sur la dépendance
énergétique à la Russie la dépendance
commerciale à la Chine et le désarmement
face aux deux celle de la France fut de
courtiser la Russie pour trianguler sa
relation avec les États-Unis en espérant
acquérir une position indépendante sans
en avoir les moyens politiques et
militaires que signifie puissance
d'équilibre quand il y a d'un côté une
démocratie qui est neutraliée depuis
plus de deux siècles qui nous a sauvés
lors de deux guerres mondiales et nous a
évité de devenir la province occidentale
du Reichs allemand ou de l'Union
soviétique et de l'autre une
cryptocratie mafieuse qui succède un
régime totalitaire ayant asservi
l'Europe pendant des décennies
les avertissements répétés des Européens
de l'Est qui savent eux ce que c'est que
l'impérialisme russe ont été rejetés
avec mépris comme des agitations de
wattes en guerre hystérique l'invasion
de l'Ukraine nous montre l'échec de ces
deux politiques et surtout l'urgence à
ne pas les poursuivre l'apaisement et le
compromis avec un dictateur n'ont jamais
marché le dictateur avance devant la
faiblesse et recule devant la force
c'est aussi simple que ça depuis
toujours si l'Europe est une paix
durable sur le continent elle doit
apprendre le langage de la puissance le
seul que les dictateurs comprennent la
troisième leçon est le degré de
nuisances de bassesse et de complicité
du parti prorus en Europe et
particulièrement en France cette
cinquième colonne des extrémistes qui
cherchent sans relâche à nous désarmer
face à un loup qu'il présente comme un
mouton qui depuis des années nous répète
que Poutine est le plus grand dirigeant
du monde qui reprennent notamment sur
les réseaux antisociaux avec les
milliers de faux comptes de trolls et de
bottes pilotés depuis Moscou sur pour
les télé RT et d'autres la propagande de
Poutine l'Ukraine n'existe pas elle est
russe ses dirigeants sont des nazis
buschkine le grand poétrus disait qu'on
nous donne une auge nous trouverons les
cochons ils sont la boussole qui
indiquent sans jamais se tromper la
direction du déshonneur par le chemin le
plus sordide depuis l'invasion de
l'Ukraine Le Pen la baronnette des
guichets de Moscou et Mélenchon le
génufleteur des plus infâmes dictatures
condamne du bout des lèvres car ne pas
le faire serait un suicide mais il ne
change pas d'avis tout est de la faute
de l'Occident surtout pas d'armes
surtout pas de sanction leur députés
européens ont refusé de voter même
l'aide humanitaire à l'Ukraine leur
parlementaire français ont refusé de
voter l'entraide la Suède et de la
Finlande dans l'OTAN lors du discours du
président de la Rada ukrainienne à
l'Assemblée mardi dernier ils ont
déserté l'hémicycle pendant que tous
leurs collègues étaient debouts pour
l'applaudir n'écoutez pas ce que disent
les dirigeants des partis de la France
russe regardez leur vote regardez leurs
gestes et vous comprendrez qu'ils n'ont
rien lâché qui sont toujours en
embuscade comme des crapauds blottis
sous une grosse pierre en attendant que
passe l'orage que faire aujourd'hui
d'abord tirer les leçons de nos erreurs
passées car nous ne les enlons pas
toutes tirer nous nous félicitons à
juste titre que l'Europe ne soit pas
divisée comme l'espérée Poutine mais
unis que notre alliance avec les
États-Unis et les autres démocraties se
soient renforcés que le soutien à
l'Ukraine reste constant que les
opinions publiques horrifiés par les
crimes de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité chaque jour sur leurs écrans
tiennent bon mais attention les
différences d'appréciations entre
européen de l'Ouest et européen de l'Est
et du Nord n'ont pas disparu et chaque
étape du conflit voit réapparaître
l'écart entre ceux qui se qualifient de
réalisme entre guillemets et ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin et plus vite les
réalistes se craignent l'escalade ils
pensent qu'il y a des lignes rouges à ne
pas franchir chaque épisode de cette
guerre prouve qu'ils ont tort en
refusant l'escalade ils en laissent le
monopole à Poutine et font perdre à
chaque fois les semaines nécessaires à
la contre-offensive c'est semaine c'est
moi parfois ce sont des milliers du
crinien qui meurent les lignes rouges
nous savons désormais qu'elles ne sont
que le fruit de nos peurs chaque fois
que Poutine les traces et qu'elles sont
franchies ils ne se passent rien comment
pourrait-il frapper plus fort alors que
son armée minée par la corruption qui
ronge son matériel l'incompétence de ces
chefs et la défiance de ces soldats est
déjà au-delà de son maximum et paralysé
sur tous les fronts quant à la rengaine
du danger nucléaire Poutine laisse
désormais mettre vedef le pochard et la
broff le croque-mort les brandir sur les
plateaux des trachetés les de Moscou il
a compris depuis la mortifiante réunion
de Samarcande
ucci et maudit l'ont mis publiquement en
piqué qu'elle lui est interdite même
parmi ces peines par ses propres alliés
mieux vaut tard que jamais c'est
maintenant qu'il faut livrer les chars
les missiles les défenses solaires et
les avions si nous voulons comme le
Prométhée le président de la République
lors de ses vœux accompagné l'Ukraine
jusqu'à la victoire finale
il est enfin une dernière raison encore
plus essentielle de ne pas répéter les
erreurs du passé les démocraties au
terme d'une lutte implacable ont vaincu
au 20e siècle les deux totalitarismes
aux dizaines de millions de morts
certains les croyaient disparus à jamais
sous nos yeux l'international des tyrans
se reforment le boucher de Moscou le
génocidaire des Ouigours en Chine le
Docteur Folamour de Corée du Nord le
massacreur de femmes de Téhéran et
quelques autres se sont regroupés leur
seul but se venger abattre l'Occident
mettra-bas la liberté la deuxième guerre
froide a commencé et depuis plusieurs
années beaucoup de dirigeants
occidentaux proclament que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre la Russie
j’espoir bien que ce discours n'est que
tactique et qu'il n'en croit pas un mot
parce que les dictateur eux l'annonce
clairement ils sont en guerre contre
nous
ils veulent achever les démocraties
qu'il croit agonisantes il n'y aurait
rien de pire que de croire que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre des gens qui
sont en guerre contre nous et qui le
disent quand on reste du monde il attend
l'issue du conflit pour voler au secours
de la victoire ce qui en espéraient une
certaine sympathie se trompe lourdement
les dirigeants bien peu démocratiques de
la plupart de ces pays se moquent de
savoir si Poutine a violé les lois
internationales ils ont même pour mantra
la justification de leur méfaits actuels
par la condamnation de notre domination
passée l'Europe doit comprendre
l'urgence de redevenir une puissance
militaire d'avoir une stratégie commune
et de consolider notre alliance avec les
autres démocraties du monde a commencé
par les États-Unis si nous n'y arrivons
pas
si nous laissons les cinquième colonnes
des fachos des trots des populistes et
des idiots utiles nous conduire à
l'aveuglement et aux renoncement alors
ce n'est pas seulement l'Ukraine demain
qui sera vaincu mais la liberté il est
temps de réarmer les démocraties face au
tyrannie du 21e siècle le peuple
héroïque du crâne nous en montre le
chemin je vous remercie
[Musique]